das ganze war
sehr geehrte damen und herren hier und
zu hause vor den bildschirmen mein name
ist hat man geboren und ich darf sie im
namen der gerade recht herzlich in der
maria theresien kaserne zur angelobung
der dritten gerade komponiere herzlich
willkommen heißen insgesamt werden heute
160 rekruten des einigungstermin
november 2021 angelobt die ehrenkompanie
wird gestellt durch die vierte kompanie
unter dem kommando von leutnant lukas
unterberger und kommentiert wird der
heutige festakt
von hauptmann peter leppin vom kommando
der gerade in kürze folgt das
ankündigungs signal und danach die
meldung einen militärisch höchst
anwesenden darauf folgt das abschreiten
der front und die frank parade und
danach wird der gerade command ist ein
grußwort an sie richten
[Musik]
das ganze
ehrenkompanie
pressemeldung das ganze recht
wir bringen hier hat man nicht man
meldet eine information der garde sowie
160 anzugehören das ideell 21 zur
feierlichen angelobung eingetreten
jawoll tagen beginnen
[Musik]
das ganze
team
kooperieren company has seen
zur frank baade das ganze recht
[Musik]
das ganze
team
kooperieren company
[Musik]
das ganze war
eine jüngsten kameraden der dritten gar
nicht dass hier kommen hand erinnern
maria theresien kaserne nach einer doch
sehr fordernden zeit vorhanden wochen im
waldviertel willkommen heißen zurück
willkommen heißen ihrer heimat garnison
anlässlich ihrer angelobung ist es auch
diesmal nicht möglich dass wir ihre
angehörigen und freunde einladen gut
bedient aber es sind immerhin
repräsentanten des zivilen lebens und
des militärischen lebens für sie extra
hier anwesend und ich möchte begrüßen
das militärisch höchst anwesenden den
militärkommandanten von wien man ist
kurt wagner hier
herzlich willkommen
und vertretern des bundes des
landeshauptmanns und des bürgermeisters
der stadt wien begrüßen herrn minister
markus kamrad der eben nebenbei auch
nicht so wie sie ist
für die hausherren oder die hausherren
des 13 wiener gemeindebezirks dass ich
begrüßen fr syke kuwait gesagt
ich darf begrüßen die herren der mit der
geistlichkeit allen voran ärzte kann
druck da harald rieck sehr alt
geschätzte kameraden sie werden jetzt
dann schon in ihre einzelnen funktionen
eingeteilt teile der dritten jahre
company natürlich als jahre die soldaten
infanterie soldaten mit noch nicht
absehbaren einsetzen die auf sie
zukommen können ansonsten einer doch
sehr fordernden ausbildung das kann ich
ihnen versprechen und es wird ihnen bei
uns sicher nicht langweilig werden
andere von ihnen werden als wachsoldaten
eingeteilt werden und wiederum andere
als funktion soldaten ich möchte für die
einzelnen funktionen und auch eines
vorweg schicken
von den gar isolaten rate ich mir
kameradschaft und pflichterfüllung
zusammenhalt und so zusammen wie die
letzten monate bewiesen haben wir die
aufträge erfüllen können jeder zählt für
die kameraden die dann den wachdienst
übernehmen von ihnen erwarten wir uns
gewissenhaftigkeit
bleiben sie gewissenhaft im umgang mit
der scharfen waffe mit dem scharfen
munition vermeiden sie fehler bleiben
sie konzentriert und für alle anderen
kameraden in diversen funktionen dienst
versehen werden sei es als kraftfahrer
sanitäter wo auch jemals gehilfen bei
vorgesetzten von ihnen erhalten wir uns
verlässlichkeit dass sie verlässlich in
ihrem job in ihrer funktion ihren
vorgesetzten zu arbeiten dass man sich
auf sie verlassen kann bestes beispiel
kraftfahrer dass das im lastkraftwagen
unter umständen kein
gefährdungspotenzial für andere da
wächst man rein ich wünsche ihnen die
restliche zeit für die restlichen monate
beim österreichischen bundesheer hier
bei uns alles erdenklich gute
bleiben sie gesund und füße lagen glück
es hatte im anschluss ein choral der
überleiter zu den worten der militär
geistlichkeit danach ist die ansprache
des militärkommandanten von wien bringt
ihr mann ist er kurz wagner und darauf
folgt das musikstück wien bleibt wien
[Musik]
geschätzter herr militärkommandant
lieber kommandant der gerade liebe
vertreter des öffentlichen und
politischen lebens aber insbesondere die
liebe kameraden die sie heute die
gelöbnisformel auf unsere republik
österreich sprechen werden sie
versprechen der republik zu dienen man
könnte fast hinzufügen in guten wie in
schlechten tagen
es ist für uns eine herausforderung
volle zeit und wir stehen knapp vor
weihnachten weihnachten heißt für uns
christen gott wird mensch nimmt gestalt
eines kindes an in bethlehem
er kommt mitten unter uns ist
solidarität gottes mit uns dass sein
gottes mit uns
was haben wir davon wird so mancher
fragen wenn gott mit uns ist dann wird
der mensch zu gott erhoben in dem
bereich gottes enthoben wenn sie nun
ihren verantwortungsvollen dienst
antreten dann sollen sie auch
solidarisch sein
kameradschaft leben miteinander das gute
wie das schwierige teilen im alltag des
dienstes dass ihnen das gelingt dazu
segne sie gott
liebe anzüge lobende kameraden
sehr geehrte ehrengäste
für den heutigen tag ist aus der aus dem
alten testament das bibelwort ausgelost
ihre mehr 30 die verse 12 16 und 17 so
spricht der herr dein schaden ist
verzweifelt böse und deine wunden sind
unheilbar doch ich will dich wieder
gesund machen und deine wunden heilen
die
heilsame liebe gottes wie sie uns auch
zu weihnachten begegnet in jesus man
könnte mit heutigen worten sagen dem
backup gottes bei ihrem er war es anders
er hat die probleme mit seinen königen
die wenigsten fragen fragten nach dem
willen gottes
einzelne beteten kurzen bildern einer
hat sogar vor moloch menschen geopfert
ihrem er hat kritisiert aber am schluss
hier auch wieder hoffnung gegeben
nach all dem was er erlebt hat und
diese hoffnung die führt auch hin
zum weihnachtsfest zum gesund machen zum
heilen der verletzungen durch gott ich
wünsche ihnen eine schöne
kameradschaft eine
interessante zeit hier wir kennen uns ja
schon von horn her und seien sie
gesegnet
sehr geehrter kommandant hohe festgäste
wie wir an zu geloben der rekruten liebe
kameraden möge gott der herr euren
friedensstiftenden dienst in unserem
österreichischen bundesheer segnen der
vater der sohn und der heilige geist
haben
sehr geehrter herr
militärkommandant werte repräsentanten
des öffentlichen lebens lieber rekruten
aus villach malerei mit dem namen gottes
des alarmes des barmherzigen
sehr geehrter herr abgeordneter frau
bezirksvorsteherin
hohe geistlichkeit und militärseelsorger
europa streiten und kam raten da gerade
insbesondere jene die jetzt angelobt
werden
zunächst habe ich mich für die worte der
seelsorge bedanken und insbesondere
freue ich mich dass wir auch irgendein
islamischen militärseelsorge wieder
heute unter uns haben
an so gelobte soldaten
ich bedanke mich bei ihnen dass sie auch
in diesen schwierigen herausforderungen
zeiten ihren dienst beim bundesheer
leisten das ist nicht einfach wir alle
haben uns
die letzten fast zwei jahre ganz anders
vorgestellt aber es war also ein
gespräch notwendig dass das
österreichische bundesheer insbesondere
natürlich auch das militärkommando
bildung die karte hier einen beitrag
leisten dass wir mit der pandemie gut
umgehen können soweit das möglich ist
als strategische reserve der republik
österreich hat das bundesheer seinen
beitrag geleistet und er war ein ganz
außerordentliche beitrag
fiele diese einsätze haben wir bereits
hinter uns gebracht aber derzeit laufen
doch durchaus
umfangreiche und die wir auch schon seit
langem durchführen wir haben wir dann
als das 1 1 hat es im burgenland wir
haben einen assistenzeinsatz hier in
wien zur bewachung von besonders
gefährdeten objekten insbesondere
botschaften internationale einrichtungen
und objekten der israelitischen
kultusgemeinde
wir unterstützen das außenministerium an
der hotline wir unterstützen das
gesundheitsministerium am montag 30
tages das sind nur ein paar beispiele
von dem was wir derzeit noch laufend und
sicherlich auch im nächsten jahr noch
machen werden
und die karte war von anfang an dabei
ich kann mich an dem jahr 2020 erinnern
wo der erste chor ohne einsatz erfolgt
ist und hier war die karte bereits von
beginn an dabei si als grund wird ihnen
sind jetzt nur ein teil dieses
herausragende verbandes garde waren
jetzt zumindest ein teil manche wir
hatten also im anschluss dann eine
weitere andere funktionen übernehmen
aber wo sie auch tätig sind es wird auf
sie persönlich ankommen dass sie ihren
beitrag zum schutz der bevölkerung
leisten
und ich
gehe hier völlig konform mit dem hof
reiten und der bereits gesprochen hat
und mit der militärseelsorge es kommt
auf die kameradschaft dann auf die
realität auf das solidarische
einstehen und auf der solidarische
miteinander
hier in der kompanie
inter garde im bundesheer aber auch in
der gesellschaft
nur so werden wir unsere
herausforderungen die wir alle haben
auch lösen können und sie werden in
ihrem treue hält auch versprechen dass
sie diesen beitrag leisten in welcher
funktion auch immer sie tätig sind jede
funktion ist ganz besonders wichtig dass
das bundesheer seine aufgaben erfüllen
kann und so ersuche ich sie alle ihre
fähigkeiten fertigkeiten und kenntnisse
in diesen dienst beim bundesheer
einzubringen dann werden sie persönlich
auch sehr viel positives aus ihrem
dienst beim bundesheer mitnehmen ich
darf die gelegenheit auch dazu verwenden
ihnen allen die hier sind und ihren
angehörigen gesegnetes weihnachtsfest zu
wünschen und alles hat endlich gute für
das jahr 2022
in diesem sinne alles gute
[Musik]
wenn ich sehr geehrten damen und herren
es folgt im anschluss die ansprache des
zivilen höchst anwesenden
landtagsabgeordnete magister marcus
schober
danach ertönt eine fanfare und leitet
über zum höhepunkt der heutigen
veranstaltung
der angelobung
die kameraden leisten den treueeid auf
die republik
das musikstück oder in österreich
leitete über zum bitten um weitere
befehle und dem abrücken der
ehrenformation
ich glaube mich in diesem sinne ja jetzt
schon von ihnen verabschieden und darf
ihnen seitens der garde eine gesegnete
adventszeit ein frohes fest und alles
gute für das jahr 2022 wünschen
sehr geehrter herr militär kommentaren
sehr geehrte frau bezirksvorsteherin
sehr hohe geistlichkeit ehrengäste aber
vor allem die wehr hat der rekruten ich
habe schon gehört zu haben intensive
wochen hinter sich ich kann mir sehr gut
vorstellen wie das in ihrer
grundausbildung gewesen ist vor allem in
diesen jahreszeiten dass es vom wetter
ja oft auch dementsprechend auch kälter
sein kann und was sie da alles geleistet
haben deswegen darf ich ihnen im namen
des wiener bürgermeisters michael ludwig
erstmal den bank übermitteln dass es
sich vom dienst beim österreichischen
bundesheer entschieden haben und darf
ich noch sagen dass die bundeshauptstadt
wien sehr stolz darauf ist dass sie
diesen dienst leisten sie haben auch
schon gehört dass wir in den letzten
jahren damit konfrontiert worden sind
das unvorhersehbare ereignisse
eingetreten sind die einige natürlich
immer eingeplant haben da war man davon
ausgegangen ist dass es in dieser form
nicht so passieren wird diese pandemie
hat uns 2020 überrascht und die stadt
wien ist sehr dankbar dafür dass das
bundesheer ab märz 2020 intensivst
unterstützt hat ich glaube nicht dass
die gesamte des dgb des straßen und
viele einrichtungen so funktioniert
hätten wäre das bundesheer auch nicht in
dieser form mit dabei gewesen und ich
bin den militärkommandanten sehr dankbar
dass wir auch da immer wieder ein blick
gehabt haben wie das ganze funktioniert
und wie diese zusammenarbeit mit den
helfern wiens perfekt bis heute
funktioniert am 26 oktober hat der
wiener bürgermeister gemeinsam mit der
bundesregierung
nationalfeiertag auch zu diesen
nationalfeiertag geredet und auch die
wichtigkeit neutralität unterstrichen
und was dann passiert ist zeigt einfach
wie spontan das österreichische
bundesheer ist im reichsgebiet hat es
einen großen brand gegeben und direkt
vom heldenplatz aus ist der hubschrauber
in das einsatzgebiet geflogen und den
brand zu bekämpfen und an dieser form
sieht man auch wie
vielseitig das bundesheer ist und in wie
vielen bereichen wie es brauchen und die
wichtigkeit des bundesheers ist der
stadt wien bewusst und wir befürworten
auch dass diese 18 neuen hubschrauber
des typs tornado gekauft werden weil wir
wissen wie wichtig es ist dass wir diese
infrastruktur haben wenn wir sie
brauchen und diese infrastruktur ist
eine sehr komplexe infrastruktur allein
die luft war für die luftsicherheit ist
etwas was von eurofighter bis zu diesen
hubschraubern sehr komplex ist und wir
haben sehr viele bereiche
österreichische bundesheer die von außen
gesehen einmal vielleicht
selbstverständlichkeit gesehen werden
wenn man hinter die kulisse sieht merkt
man was die tausenden menschen der
bundeswehr leisten und welche sicherheit
sie damit für das land garantieren ganz
wichtig ist und das hat ihr kommandant
schon gesagt das österreichische
bundesheer funktioniert nicht ohne ihre
leistung sie werden in die
unterschiedlichsten bereiche eingeteilt
werden aber im gesamten funktioniert das
bundesheer nur deshalb weil auch sie
sich für den dienst entschieden haben
und sie können davon ausgehen dass auch
ihre vorgesetzten einmal hier gestanden
sind und sich dann dementsprechend
entschieden haben für das bundesheer
tätig zu sein und das ist ganz wichtig
weil ich glaube dass das bundesheer sehr
viel dazu beigetragen hat dass die
republik österreich heutzutage so
internationales ansehen hat wie es hat
allein durch die auslandseinsätze die
seit den 60er jahren getätigt werden ist
es möglich dass green der einzige unter
sitz in der europäischen union ist und
dass wir nach diesen internationalen
stellenwert hat und es wurde ja schon
erwähnt dass heute aktuell 3100
kameraden und kameradinnen von ihnen im
einsatz sind es sind 600 davon im
gesundheitsbereich tätig 1400 im
grenzeinsatz im assistenzeinsatz und in
der bewachung der botschaften und 1000
soldaten und soldatinnen sind im ausland
tätig und das ist etwas was ich auch
hier immer wieder betonen möchte diese
1000 soldaten und soldatinnen sind
repräsentanten für die republik
österreich und sie gewährleisten damit
dass österreich eine so hohe
internationale reputation hat und dafür
möchte ich mich bedanken
selbstverständlich ist das thema
pandemie und caron ein großes thema das
gemerkt ihrer ausbildung und hier hinten
stets großgeschrieben wir schützen
österreich und sie werden jetzt auch ein
gelöbnis sprechen wo sie genau diesen
schutz geloben werden und ich darf sie
vielleicht auch dazu suchen und sie
werden in ihren gesprächen die sie mit
kameraden kameraden an familie und
freunde haben oft zu diesem thema
sprechen das österreichische bundesheer
agiert immer stumm lagen die
wissenschaftlich und dementsprechend
auch montiert sind und von ihren
vorgesetzten werden sie auch meldungen
hören warum wir diesen einsatz machen
warum das österreichische bundesheer die
besten strategie und viele andere dinge
vertritt vielleicht erkundigen sie sich
auch in diesen orten genau und gehen auf
jene menschen ein die derzeit ängste
haben und die meines erachtens auch
berechtigte ängste haben aber die man
aufklären kann und wenn sie österreich
schützen dann versuchen sie auch in
diesen gesprächen sich zu informieren
und darauf einzuwirken dass man gewisse
dinge wie zb eine impfung oder des
jungen befürworten könnte das ist auch
ein schutz österreichs wäre das letzte
was wir brauchen ist eine spaltung der
gesellschaft und ich sehe das
österreichische bundesheer auch immer
als einen faktor dafür dass die
gesellschaft zusammen rückt sie kommen
aus den unterschiedlichsten bereichen
ist sie kommen aus den
unterschiedlichsten ausbildungen aber
das was sie eint ist das sie heute
geloben österreich zu schützen und dafür
möchte ich mich bedanken und möchte noch
einen aufruf machen dass sie vielleicht
genau anschauen welche möglichkeiten das
österreichische bundesheer hat ich bin
selbst mediziner physiker ich bin
dankbar für die ausbildung die ich
genossen habe und vielleicht bleibt der
eine oder andere von ihnen in der miliz
oder auch wird berufssoldat das
österreichische bundesheer kann
diesbezüglich auch nachwuchs brauchen
und ich wünsche ihnen alles gute
gefallen dass sie immer gesund aus ihren
einsätzen wieder in die kaserne und zu
ihrer familie zurück kommen ich wünsche
ihnen ebenfalls vor weihnachten ein
gutes neues jahr und endet mit den
worten es lebe das österreichische
bundesheer ist lebe die republik
österreich
[Musik]
was ganze
druck da gerade madrid
[Musik]
angestellte guten fortschritten
recht gut so
[Musik]
die klu dann spricht mir nach ich gelobe
publik österreich
folgt zu schützen und der freundliche
tag und mit der waffe zu verteidigen
ich gelobe
den gesetzen und den gesetzmäßigen
behörde
zunächst
alle befehle meiner vorgesetzten
glücklich und genau zu befolgen und
mit allen meinen kräften
der republik österreich und
dem österreichischen volk
[Musik]
ein geteiltes solar 3
in siegen druck der gerade ein break
[Musik]
das ganze
das ist ganz nah
[Musik]
die company
and company presse
das ganze recht
meldet weniger feierlichen angelobung
und bittet
das ganze
ihre company
[Musik]
hat er komplett übernehmen abrücken